our view of the history of philosophy
science or really human thought in
general have a tendency to be rather
biased I can tell you how many times
I've watched something like a YouTube
video where they go through the history
of philosophy and present a rather
one-sided and very narrow picture of the
actual history we love to talk about
people like Plato and Aristotle or John
Locke and Nietzsche and Kierkegaard and
sometimes also Confucius if we're
generous but this view of presenting
history starting with the ancient Greeks
and then moving on to the Renaissance
and then the Enlightenment and all the
way up to today is a very Eurocentric
view of history and the history of
philosophy and it ignores a very
significant point in time and as
philosophical and scientific culture
that was very significant I'm talking of
course about the philosophical works of
the early Islamic world and not only
were these philosophers who are very
significant and important in their own
rights riding on themes like optics and
astronomy metaphysics and music medicine
all these different kinds of fields but
they're also important because they are
the ones who often preserved the old
Greek traditions and then transmitted it
or handed it over indirectly to the
European thinkers which then led to
things like the Renaissance indeed a lot
of people argue that there wouldn't be a
renaissance without these Arabic and
Islamic philosophers and yet not many of
these individuals are mentioned today by
people when discussing something like
the history of philosophy a lot of us in
the so-called West don't realize how
much we are indebted to these people and
how much they have affected the very
culture and world that we live in I've
made a few videos on this subject in the
past I made for example one video on
even Sina or the Persian philosopher
also known as Avicenna a prominent great
figure I made another video on the under
Lucien philosopher eben to fail and his
masterpiece Hiab Noxon and then finally
I also made one on eben Hal dune the
historian and philosopher and all of
these can be found on my chat
but today I'm gonna be rewinding the
clock a bit and talk about the very
inception of Muslim and Arabic
philosophy in what is known as the
translation movement and particularly of
two most important and prominence of
these early philosophers al Kindi and Al
Farabi nothing ever really happens in a
vacuum and Muslim and Arabic philosophy
is no exception what needs to be
understood from the get-go is that these
people are in deeply indebted to the
ancient Greeks and their philosophical
traditions and writings and that's not
to say that these people didn't have
original ideas or anything that but all
those ideas are based on these sort of
groundwork that the Greeks sort of built
and also on the Islamic sources like the
Quran for example and this includes
people like Plato and Socrates and Galen
and perhaps above all Aristotle but also
some later traditions which will become
clear pretty soon with the inception and
spread of the Islamic religion the
Muslims the early Muslims conquered most
of the known world at the time the
Middle East and North Africa and Persia
all the way to Afghanistan
it is said or thought that Mohammed is
to have said that you are to seek
knowledge all the way to China and a lot
of these early Muslims really took that
message to heart very early on a lot of
different sciences and fields of thought
started to appear in this new culture
this new Empire everything from how to
understand God through theology and
jurisprudence and and and mysticism and
a bunch of different movements were
heavily discussed at the time but there
was one group of people who were
particularly interested in what was
known as the ancient wisdoms that is you
know the Greek text text written by old
sages from another country in Greece who
were sort of concealed by a language
barrier because they didn't speak Greek
obviously
and these people who really cultivated
this knowledge later became known as the
fanciful tradition which is really just
an Arabic version of the word philosophy
ax and this would give birth to some of
the most famous thinkers in Middle
Eastern history in the late eighth and
ninth centuries under the Ambassador
fate there was a great flourishing of
learning in the new capital Baghdad one
of the caleb's either maybe haroon
rasheed or his son al Mamoon established
an institution that's known as the Bayt
al-hikma which means the House of Wisdom
which was a place in Baghdad where
intellectual discussions were being had
regarding different subjects one of the
most significant of these activities in
this Bayt al-hikma this House of Wisdom
was what is known as the translation
movement in which a lot of texts were
gathered from all around the world and
then translated by the translation were
led by some of these individuals that I
would discuss and the Greeks were
particularly popular at the time because
they had a pretty good reputation a
whole myriad of texts were gathered in
Baghdad and then translated into Arabic
now before we get into actual philosophy
we need to lay some groundwork first
something that it's very important to
understand and know about is a
philosophical school of thought or
movement known as neoplatonism this is a
school that's usually traced back to an
Alexandrian philosopher called platanus
who lived in the well around the 3rd
century AD and the school that followed
him consider itself to be part of the
sort of platonic school the Platonic
heritage sort of speak but there are a
lot of things that differ it or a lot of
things in which it differ from the
philosophy of Plato himself which is why
it's considered its very own school the
philosophy of neoplatonism isn't easy to
explain in simple terms but a general
outlook can be said to be something like
this there is something called the one
an absolute principle that is beyond
space and time being and non-being and
is characterized by absolute perfection
this one flows over or m
it's the created world in a few steps
the first emanation is often called the
first intellect that is pure
intellectualizing and the highest form
of being whose very nature is self
reflexive thinking then there is the
universal soul and finally the
phenomenal world that we experience in
fact many of the terms that would be
discussed by the Arabic philosophers
were borrowed from the Greeks and
returned as important concepts things
like intellect so being for matter and
so on the school of neoplatonism in some
sense tried to reconcile the
philosophies of Plato and Aristotle
sometimes claiming that they were
actually trying to say the same thing
and thus they would commentaries on both
their works this movement of
Neoplatonism and their ideas that I just
mentioned as well as their
interpretations of Aristotle in
particular would have a lasting and
significant effect on the later Muslim
tradition moving back to Baghdad in the
late eighth and early ninth centuries
the translation movement was by now in
full force and a lot of different texts
were being translated this movement was
led by a few individuals among them a
Christian thinker who 9i Benicia and
later his son Ishaq even her nine they
weren't too creative with the names back
then but an even more famous group of
translators were gathered around a
Muslim thinker and one that we come
known later as the very first of the
Arabic philosophers and his name was
upper use of yaqoob even a shock and
kindy
[Music]
we don't actually know too much about
our kindy on his personal life we know
that he was from arabic descent and was
maybe born in Kufa where he seems to
have received his basic education but he
then moved sort of he moved up in the
world so to speak and eventually moved
to the newly established capital Baghdad
and there he worked for him became
pretty close with some of the famous
ambassador lives like Alma Mona Lama
TASM and they employed him to the newly
established House of Wisdom the baited
jicama where he was charged with leading
the translation of Greek texts it was
through this work that he also gathered
his own knowledge and a lot of the
sciences and philosophies that he would
later himself become known for he seems
to have been a pretty respected man
during most of his life he was even
employed to be the personal tutor to the
kala falmouth Azam's son which must have
been one of the most prestigious jobs
you could ever have not only did alkane
they lead the translation of Greek text
but he also wrote a lot of his own
philosophical works it's thought that he
wrote hundreds of works a huge body of
text in a number of different fields
including metaphysics ethics medicine
psychology mathematics astronomy music
and optics but sadly very few of these
texts survived today one of the things
that I'll keenly try to do was to take
these Greek teachings these Greek
philosophies which he considered to be
in some cases universal truths and then
apply them to the newly sort of Islamic
framework he tackled questions of
theology like they're the kalam
theologians discussions on the nature of
God and the soul and he argued that the
Quran the sort of sacred scripture of
the Muslims was in complete harmony with
Greek philosophy while the Greek and by
this point the Arabic philosophers dealt
with a lot of different subjects on
kindy and a lot of his contemporaries
considered one of these fields to be
especially important and especially
Noble and that is what could be called
rational theology that is philosophy
that deals with God and
to al-kindi metaphysics was primarily
and almost entirely made up of theology
so he sort of equated metaphysics with
theology he writes in one of his
surviving works called on first
philosophy that the noblest part of
philosophy and the highest in degree is
first philosophy by which I mean the
science of the first truth who is the
cause of all truth to him studying the
Greek text can only benefit the Muslims
and their religion in his metaphysical
works he tackles very difficult
questions about the nature of God and
how God relates to creation in the
religion of Islam the basic theological
principle is something known in Arabic
as tawheed which means that there is no
god but God as claim to the Shahada and
also that God is absolutely one now
al-kindi affirms this theology in his
writings and applies what's known as the
negative theology that is that nothing
can be said or described about God God
doesn't have qualities or attributes
like human beings does or in the sense
that human being does because that would
compromise his oneness and after all God
is as I said absolutely one in every
year aspect this isn't an uncommon
position to hold in Islamic philosophy
at all it's quite common but of kindy
was probably one of the first to explain
her to talk about it in a philosophical
language he further presents the idea
that everything in the world in the
created world is made up of both oneness
and many nests so you talk about
something like you or me I am one
because I am a person I am a concrete
object by then by the sense of being a
oneness but I'm also many nests in the
sense that I can consist I consist of
many different parts parts of my body
parts of my source of attributes and
qualities I can also say for example
that I am 25 years old which also
implies are many nasaan multiplicity
because there is the concept of me and
then also the concept of time which it's
which separates that that creates a
duality in that sense nothing in the
created world is absolutely one but
stems from something that is
essentially one and that one is God
therefore no category that is applied to
created things can also be applied to
God because anything that's applied to
created things they also have meninist
contained within them and God doesn't he
himself writes the following the true
one possesses no matter or form quantity
or quality or relation and is not
described by any of the other categories
nor does he possess genus difference
individual property common accident or
motion he's there for nothing but pure
oneness this problem of God's attributes
or qualities that are described in the
quran was one of the most hotly debated
issues in theology at the time with some
arguing that those quran verses that
described his qualities should be read
metaphorically or symbolically and
others that wanted to read it literally
al Kindi is sort of arrives at the scene
here with a strongly negative theology
that is perhaps you could say more in
line with the school of the Motta's
allah for example even though he
disagrees with them on several other
points as well what he then says about
God's relationship to creation and the
very process of creation is very
original and interesting and something
that hasn't really been repeated much
later on in theology and philosophy he
argues that when God creates something
when he creates the world or creates
things he's actually bestowing oneness
upon them and thus making you know that
oneness creating that oneness which
makes a thing a thing now remember
everything in the world he argues is
consists of both men eNOS and oneness
without the oneness of me I wouldn't
exist there wouldn't be a me so what God
is doing is he's bestowing one as he's
giving things oneness which is his own
essence he's giving his own essence of
oneness two things and thus they exist
they are created another controversial
topic in these circles at the time was
the question of the Eternity of the
world is the world created a specific
point in time as seems to be implied by
the Quran or has it always existed
eternally now the Muslim philosophers
are those belonging to the philosophic
tradition usually argued that the world
is indeed eternal and followed Aristotle
in that regard but they were harshly
criticized by a lot of other theologians
and thinkers for example one very famous
example is a bohemian al-ghazali
theologian and sufi and thinker from the
11th and 12th century and he listed this
doctrine of the Eternity of the world as
one of the reasons behind him calling
some of these philosophers like Ivan
Cena a Kaffir or unbelievers alongside a
couple of others factors as well what is
interesting about al-kindi is that he
sort of breaks this trend of the
philosophical position although breaking
the trend before it actually existed
since he's the first philosopher but he
argues that the world is created at a
specific point in time in God and the
time does must have a beginning
following the Neoplatonic system that I
mentioned earlier he also discusses the
concept of the human intellect and soul
the first intellect that principle that
is the first emanation or creation of
the one is distinct from human
individual intellect but they have an
important relationship while humans can
potentially know things like universal
concepts and perceive things through
their senses they can't actually come to
know things without being given that
knowledge by the universal intellect in
the book the Cambridge companion to
Arabic philosophy
Peter Adamson uses a very good metaphor
of a piece of wood and fire the wood can
potentially be hot just as the human
intellect can potentially know universal
concepts but it requires something like
fire for example in this case the
universal intellect to make it hot he
also views the soul al-kindi that is you
use the soul as something clearly
immaterial and separated from the body
the goal of life for the individual
humanist disassociate his soul as much
as possible from being entangled with
the physical body which only leads to
suffering and instead focusing on the
intellectual side of the soul in order
to reach the entirely intelligible world
after death
since the soul is separated from the
body and thus survives echoing many
mystics and
it's he argues that it's no use focusing
on the physical world or physical life
as everything in this world can be taken
away instead we should focus on
intellectual activity which is the
ultimate source of happiness as
mentioned earlier our kindy also had a
strong interest in what we were not
today as natural science or just science
but of course at these times philosophy
and science in the sense that this today
wasn't really separated or considered
two different fields but among these
interests he was particularly also
interested in music he appears to have
been a musician and an odd player which
of course gives him extra credits in my
book and he wrote a lot of texts and
works on music in fact music would be
considered by an kindy and also
following his example later on
considered to be part of the category of
mathematics he for example discusses the
therapeutic uses of music in sort of
health and so on and the study of music
generally would become very important
and prominent parts of Muslim and Arabic
philosophy and al-kindi
kind of laid the groundwork for that as
well the relationship between the
Philosopher's and what is sometimes
conceived of as Orthodox Islam is
sometimes described as being rather
shaky and sometimes even hostile it is
true that some philosophers later on and
this early stage as well were criticized
by individuals like a Lagasse alia that
I talked about but to talk about an
orthodoxy especially at this stage is
very anachronistic and creates some
problems even if Phalke Indy's ideas
doesn't always jive too well with what
became known as orthodoxy later we must
remember that at this time a lot of
different ideas religious ideas were
being tossed around
nothing was clearly formed and al-kindi
represents one of these movements
alchemy was a devout Muslim he wrote
many works where he used his philosophy
to comment on and interpret the Quran
one of his missions was to bring the
knowledge of the Ancients to benefit the
Muslims and their understanding of God
and scripture he didn't view philosophy
in revelation as being in opposition to
it
at all but quite the opposite that they
complemented each other he argued that
the truth that is reached by
philosophers and on one side and on
prophets on the other is in fact the
same truth the only difference being
that for prophets that knowledge is more
wide and and and sort of fuller and it's
also received instantly without any sort
of intellectual strivings about for a
philosopher reaching that truth takes
many years of study and education and
even then it isn't as complete as that
truth that the prophet receives but the
truth in itself remains the same and
thus revelation and philosophy to
al-kindi and analogous followers were
not in contradiction to each other at
all
well he seems to have been close with
caleb's like Alma more than 1,000 some
of the later caleb's that followed
didn't look as kindly to his ideas and
certain theological movements started to
rise in power that were a lot more
hostile to him according to some sources
it appears that like Indy lost much of
his status and reputation by the end of
his life and he died around the Year 873
interestingly despite of his important
contribution to the translation movement
a lot of his own works fell into
obscurity until fairly recently part of
the reason for this is that he was
overshadowed by some of his successors
one of which was of course the
monumentous and very famous eben cena
but there was another one an earlier
philosopher who would sort of carry on
the legacy that I can be started and
further developed the inherited Greek
tradition with such competence that he
became known later as the second teacher
after Aristotle this man was Abu Nazir
Muhammad bin Muhammad but he's better
known by the name Al Farabi
similarly to al-kindi the information on
the personal life of Al Farabi is rather
sparse he was likely from the larger
Persian region possibly from far above
Hasan he traveled a lot including to
Damascus and Aleppo and Cairo and Egypt
which was by that time ruled by the
smiley fatima dynasty but he spent spent
most of his time at least his
intellectual life writing most of his
work in the Ambassador capital of
Baghdad he seems to have had some
contact with the ruling elite and the
caleb's of Baghdad but not to the extent
of al Kindi he brought a few works for
ministers here and there but he probably
wasn't dining with the caliphs let's say
in Baghdad he worked on a lot of
philosophical works and ideas and he was
quite closely acquainted with a lot of
Christian thinkers some of which were
his students al farabi is religious
affiliation has been discussed and
debated some claiming that he may have
been a Shia others that he was a Sunni
but at least in most likelihood he
identified as a Muslim in fact when he
writes historically on the subject in
appearance of philosophy one of his
works he seemingly criticizes some of
the Church Fathers by stating that then
the teaching meaning Greek philosophy
came to an end in Rome while it
continued in Alexandria until the king
of the Christians looked into the matter
the bishops assembled and took counsel
together on which parts of Aristotle's
teachings were to be left in place and
which were to be discontinued they firm
the opinion that the books on logic were
to be taught up to the end of the
esoteric figures but not what comes
after it since they thought that that
would harm Christianity he then explains
that teaching the rest of the logical
works remained private until the coming
of Islam in fact like al Kindi alpha
Robby's mission was similar in the sense
that he wanted to synthesize the Greek
traditions of Aristotle and his later
Alexandrian commentators with his
contemporary Muslim environment and the
intellectual discussions and theological
discussions that were being had at the
time although the conclusions
that he draws and a lot of his
philosophy differs dramatically from his
predecessors and in fact al-farabi
would in a lot of ways eclipse
completely alkane these works
he doesn't however seem to have been
very well known at all during his own
lifetime like I said he had some
contacts with a ruling elite but he
wasn't the world-famous renowned scholar
by any stretch yet his works and
philosophy is today considered very
significant in the development of Muslim
philosophy and of course our
intellectually interesting and valuable
in their own right as well about half a
century after Al Farabi the perhaps most
famous Muslim philosopher of all time a
Ben Sina
wrote that he could never understand
Aristotle's works until he read al
farabi x' commentaries on them he was
incredibly important in handing down the
knowledge of the Greeks to the
arabic-speaking world and influenced
thinkers like eben Cena they already
mentioned but also the Jewish
philosopher Maimonides and and many many
more
again like al Kindi Farabi was a
polymath he wrote on logic mathematics
metaphysics music psychology and even
political philosophy we will go through
a couple of the more juicy of these and
we will start like we did last time with
alpha Robby's metaphysics there's a lot
to unpack here and not a lot of modern
research has been done on alpha Robby's
philosophy yet but it is clear that he
much like his predecessor follows the
Neoplatonic system where the first cause
which al farabi identifies with God
emanates into lesser modes of being his
original contribution to this system is
that he includes or incorporates the
Ptolemaic cosmological astronomical
system into it in a way that is both
baffling and incredibly interesting he
divides this process of emanation from
the one or the first cause to the first
intellect and soul and so on into six
principles or stages the first is the
first cause or God followed by secondary
causes or secondary intellects what Al
Farabi does here is to identify these
intellects with the nine celestial
spheres of the Ptolemaic system
astronomy in this view the heavens are
made up of spheres that are associated
with different planets that were then
known like Mars Jupiter and well the Sun
because the Sun was considered a planet
at that point to al-farabi these are all
secondary intellects that descend in the
process of emanation from the first
cause until we reach the so called sub
lunar world that is the sphere below the
moon here we find the third principle
the active intellect followed by the
fourth soul than v form and lastly six
matter the different secondary
intellects that are associated with the
nine celestial spheres are also sort of
identified as the angels of theology and
Revelation which sort of places this
philosophy very neatly within a familiar
monotheistic framework which is very
smart obviously it may all sound very
crazy and kind of is but it's also a
very smart an interesting way of
incorporating a lot of different ideas
and sort of themes and thoughts that
were popular at the time the first cause
or God is one alone and much like al
Kindi he sort of uses a negative
theology to talk about God but he
differs from al Kindi in a significant
way in his view of what metaphysics is
remember - al Kindi metaphysics is by
definition theology that is the first
philosophy the study of God whereas for
an Farabi and also for had been seen and
later thinkers metaphysics is simply the
study of being of existence itself his
psychology or the study of the soul and
really everything else that he writes is
then based on this very Princeton this
metaphysical principle with the with the
emanation of the different spheres and
intellects he develops a kind of
teleological ideal where everything in
the world has a specific purpose or goal
in mind for its creation the goal for
the human being is constant
intellectualizing in other words we has
rational beings are to develop our
intellect from being merely physical to
eventually reach a perfection of
intellect and thus unite
with the active intellect that is the
intellect that is associated with the
sphere under the moon the sub lunar
world you remember that this is known as
the third principle in the process of
emanation from the first cause and this
active intellect this third principle is
very important for the psychology the
philosophy of psychology for al-farabi
the mind of the human being is dependent
on this intellect and all our
intellectualizing our intellect
accompanied the active intellect is what
causes the human being to think here he
uses the metaphor of light and vision
the active intellect in this case is the
light that gives the potential a vision
the sort of ability to actually see
things he writes Sun gives vision to
lights and by the lights acquired from
the Sun vision actually sees when before
it had only the potential to see by that
light vision sees the Sun itself which
is the cause for it actually seeing and
furthermore actually sees the colors
which previously were only potentially
the objects of vision the vision that
was potentially thereby becomes actual
thus it is with the rational human mind
and the active intellect it leads the
mind to think rationally and also
through that rationality being able to
live virtuously and act according to
right and wrong eventually the human
mind becomes like the active intellect
and ultimate happiness can be achieved
perhaps it should be surprising that a
philosopher considers philosophy itself
to be the key to happiness but I have a
hard time accepting the notion that if
you want to be happy we should think
more but this concept of happiness and
well-being carries over nicely to one of
the most interesting aspects of Alpha
lobby's philosophy and his works which
is his sort of ethical and moral ideas
and what we could even call a kind of
political philosophy he wrote several
works on this subject the best known of
which is a book called al-madinah al
fadela
or the virtuous City and he has a
wonderful way of discussing Lee
ship and rulership in a way that I think
is rhetorically quite brilliant now he
accepts the notion that the body and the
soul are separate like a lot of
philosophers would and both of these
faculties can become ill or sick now
when the body is sick you go see a
physician and thus the role of the
physician is to look after the health of
the human body the bodies of individuals
now the political leader like a king or
a ruler or whatever you want to have it
to al-farabi is like a physician to the
soul thus it is the job of the Statesman
to look after the souls of the
individuals in his society the virtuous
regime or society and the best kind of
society is one where the souls of its
inhabitants are as healthy as possible
he explains himself that the one who
cures Souls is the Statesman and he is
also called the king what is happiness
of the soul then you may ask well twelve
Farabi this is distinguished by always
acting in a good manner always doing
what's good and avoiding anything that
is evil or wicked now of course we can
get into discussions about ethics and
what constitutes good and evil but so
al-farabi
this is sort of based on ideas that it
was handed down by Aristotle and also
based on a lot of the religious
doctrines and religious moral ideas that
were prominent at his time he then also
lists a number of different political
systems under which people live or have
lived historically including democracy
and tries to conclude which is the best
one he understood that the ideal
virtuous society he was envisioning was
next to impossible but it still held it
as a principle that should be strived
for one where the ultimate of the
ultimate happiness of its citizens are
in focus this is the idea of society one
where the citizens are as healthy as
possible in terms of their souls a
subject that was most important to Al
Farabi was logic it was the prerequisite
for everything else that I discussed
from metaphysics to physics to ethics
and politics and psychology everything
was based on logic this was incredibly
important to him
and on this subject he also tackles the
question of revelation much like a king
did but in a rather different way the
philosophers through logic primarily and
demonstrative proofs can attain perfect
truth and complete certitude but this
knowledge this perfect truth is only
available to a certain group of people
who have the capacity and interest to
pursue the philosophical road to
ultimate happiness but what about the
rest of the people the majority of the
population who don't have this capacity
or interest
well this to al-farabi is where the
prophets come in it is the role of the
Prophet to take the same truth that the
Philosopher's arrive at through
demonstrative reasoning and turn it into
a rhetorical form that can be properly
understood by the general population by
most people in society some would of
course say that this sort of undermines
the role of the prophets and almost puts
him in a secondary position next to a
philosopher and while this wouldn't be
entirely wrong to say something like
that one should be careful not to
generalize as well there's a whole ocean
of interesting things to talk about when
it comes to Al Farabi and not all of
these can fit into this one video he was
also a musician for example and wrote
extensively on music theory he was an
ood player much like al Kindi was and it
is sometimes thought that Al Farabi is
actually the one or the person who added
the fifth string to the to the youth to
the Arabic lute however some argue that
it was actually al Kindi who had the
fifth string or possibly it was none of
them the point is that music and and
music theory was an important point were
important parts of alpha Robby's
writings and philosophy he wrote among
other things an extensive work called
kitab-o-moosa al Kabeer or the great
book of music in which he talks about
several aspects of a speck music theory
including the modal system the sort of
scale system model system known as
mahkumat music was closely connected to
mathematics and there may have been some
influence from the Pythagorean theories
of harmonic ratios al farabi for example
distinguishes between theoretical and
practical aspects of music and in his
great book of new
he tackles subjects such as instruments
which he divides into natural
instruments including the human voice
and artificial instruments which
includes pipes and lutes like the old
and so on he talks about melodies and
rhythm and how melodies are constructed
as well as but those melodies based on
how they are constructed can invoke or
symbolize he played a pretty important
role in systematizing music theory in
the Arabic language something that
thinkers like eben Cena would later pick
up on but he also influenced some later
Latin music theorist Al Farabi thus in
an indirect way has influenced our own
European music the sort of tradition
just as he has other fields of
philosophy after traveling and writing
for many years and without really
gaining any fame during his own lifetime
it is thought that Al Farabi passed away
in Damascus in the year 950 alkeine D&L
Farabi were both significant early
figures in the files of a tradition they
differed on some significant points and
ideas like the question of the Eternity
of the world but they left a lasting
impact on the future of Muslim
philosophy and on the intellectual
history of the world in general they
arose out of a cultural context in which
the gathering of knowledge was one of
the main agendas and in which an
institution like the House of Wisdom
Bayt al-hikma in Baghdad could flourish
the period from about the start of the
translation movement and the earlier
Basset Caliphate to around the turn of
the first millennium is sometimes
referred to as the Golden Age of Islam
and while there are some problems
related to that statement it is true
that the intellectual activity and
achievements of this period is
incredibly significant and something
that should be highly admired the
following centuries saw further
developments and periods of great
flourishing as well as periods of
stagnation and setbacks and there are a
number of subjects and people that I
would love to cover in future videos but
for now I hope this short video on these
particular thinkers have been
satisfactory and at least sort of
instigating a hunger within you for more
knowledge feel free to continue this
discussion in the comments section we
can discuss different
because you can ask questions that you
are wondering about and you can also
leave suggestions for future subjects
and future videos I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]